Jim Harbaugh has made more in bonuses
than any other college football coach
raising his salary to $12 million this
season from his base salary of 7.63
million according to front office Sports
so how did he make $4 million in bonus
cash well he made 500k for Michigan
winning the Big 10 East title then when
they won the Big 10 title he tacked on
another $1 million he made 500k from
Michigan making an appearance in the
college football playoffs and then of
course another $1 million from winning
the national title and just when you
think it'll end there for him he gets
another one million because Michigan is
required to pay Harbaugh $1 million
annually to his life insurance policy
bringing his final salary to $12 million
and at the end of the day he has his
guys to thank for it